we always love to see celebs who have
gotten really star struck over meeting
their favorite star and kristen stewart
is just like the rest of us
yeah kristin was interviewed by w
magazine for its best performances issue
and admitted she became totally star
struck during a recent encounter with
scream star nev campbell take a look
i saw nev campbell in a restaurant the
other day and um
i was like
my i looked over my shoulder and did
this thing where i hate when people do
to me where they like look and then snap
back and pretend like they didn't see or
something i'm like just come say hi
and then my friend was like you should
just go say and i was like no way
and then she invited us to sit down and
like chat for a minute it's funny who
actually star strikes you it's never who
you expect it's a physical thing it's
like maybe you love a musician maybe you
love an actor so much but you see them
you're like yeah cool that's them
they're a person there are some people
that just get in there physically and
then your body goes ah
cause like logically there's no reason
it's a person but i get it